[Music]
we had a wonderful moment backstage
where I kind of popped in to be hostly
and say hello I hope you don't mind me
saying you were
topless that's appropriate to say that's
see it's shirtless if you don't have
boobs
[Applause]
but so for me it would be
[Laughter]
tough I had that when I was a kid I I
swam with a t-shirt on until I was 18
and then nothing changed I just got
confident
oh I can't wait for that
day but I come in you're without top and
we always hug we always hug as we just
did that that's not Chas that's real
that's what we do that's what we do to
prove that we don't have weapons on
us I do give a little
Pat I give a small Pat I don't want to
be John mcaning with a duct tape gun
anyone Die
Hard uh so you were you were without
your shirt and I came in and we always
hug but we've never topless hugged never
and there was this is an a testament to
our friendship zero hesitation No in
fact it seemed like you were more
enthusiastic
and I knew what was coming cuz it was a
delight it was it's always it's always
great to see it it was warm from my body
heat cool from your hands it was
beautiful we were a living jar of Icy
Hot we could have helped someone with
their arthritis is what I'm saying Help
Shaquille O'Neal out does he have it
he's a Icy Hot spokesman is he for he's
a spokesman for many things yeah he says
he says yes to everything he will I want
to see like he has like Shack everything
yeah just anything he has a shack soda
which I think is
ridiculous cuz people have to you know
be scientists to make
sodas Shaq doesn't just have high
fructose corn syrup in his Pantry mixing
up his own soda you're like you know it
be delicious was that voice
offensive it all I I appreciate that he
started with like strawberry cream soda
like you don't even he didn't even start
with a cola like that's if you going to
make a soda company start with a cola
and Branch out you mean his Flagship
operation was a strawberry cream soda I
think I speak for everyone when I say we
don't want Dairy in our
soda cream yeah Shaq's getting bad
advice he's a giant man have you ever
met met Shaq I've never met Shaq I did
his weird TV show I like the fact that
we're here on the stage to you means
that I might have met
Shaq most people haven't met
[Applause]
Shaq what if I turn the card over and
the first question is have you met
sh I can't wait for funches to be on the
show which NBA players have you
met none of them no not I've met Scotty
P once no tipping pipping I met him when
I was a child at a a museum he was
helping people make flip
books he was just trying to stop people
from learning or absorbing he's like
that flip
books that that horse is Galloping
pretty fast he was good at it why was he
making flip books he probably had
community service or
[Laughter]
something
is there a way to get a synthetic you in
my life all the time I just want this
around I want you on the dashboard of my
car I want you on my mantle piece I just
feel like if we could all have a little
bit of funches in our lives wouldd be
better
off a I can we agree with
that I'm just excit I mean look at this
I know how you tricked people into
giving you a
show where you just hang out with your
friends I'm not a
celebrities Zach RPS and then thers out
here just
dancing how do you how do we live like
this I don't know I just wanted to have
my life happening in front of cameras
and an audience basically figured it out
we did do it out I love
[Music]
it